this is Startalk here's the deal from
Jerry James Jerry James says super and
coming to us from Earth and Facebook
Jerry James says Superman absorbs
radiation from the Sun like a solar
battery and converts it into his powers
this is what he's saying not me if he
never used his powers wouldn't that
radiation build up inside of him causing
him to admit dangerous radiation to
everyone around him by the way if he is
doing that wouldn't he just be a
radioactive person yes
and he had a very high temperature as I
said earlier you can't store energy in
an unlimited way without you getting hot
it's right how it's how nature manifests
itself so no no he'd be very hot you
know he was coming from long and just
carry a Geiger counter
that's his breathalyzer
mrs. breath yes so no I don't see I
don't see that happening
plus our claim was our star somehow
nourished his energy but we know how to
take all the energy from our Sun you
know my solar panels and things right
he's not gonna absorb it faster or
better than a solar panel will so I'm
not I'm not I'm not there on that okay
that's it yeah guys all right Benny
steals with his bare hands I'm good with
that
but flying and blue pantyhose I'm good
with that
was that but but taking energy from the
Sun no no no no okay not a million years
all right
this is Startalk